car renaud muselier président de la
région paca bonsoir arnaud muselier
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on vous étiez je ne sais pas si
vous voulez toujours un président de
région très en colère ce week-end samedi
vous avez donné concrètement trois jours
à la grande distribution pour
s'expliquer sur cette vente massive de
masse à ce que déjà vous avez eu des
réponses alors je suis pas du tout en
colère je suis la colère est mauvaise
conseillère
je suis très attentif sur ce qui se
passe et à la législation et aux
annonces dans mon pays ça fait deux mois
que nous sommes en guerre où les masques
et maintenant il ya une forme de guerre
de communication pour savoir si ces
masques seront ont été fabriquées et cas
mais c'est vrai que c'est très
inquiétant cette histoire pourquoi vous
avez fait un reportage que tout à fait
intéressant par exemple chez carrefour
cet après-midi le masque a été fabriqué
le 1er avril l'autorisation du
gouvernement pour faire bloquer les
masques date du 24 avril entre le 24
avril et le 4 mai vous avez deux
week-ends avec le pont du 1er mai qui
l'obligé en trois jours fériés en chine
expliquez moi comment on peut fabriquer
des masques des ventes sur le territoire
français pendant que nous les cherchons
dans les pharmacies pour les médecins
pour les pharmaciens dans les hôpitaux
il ya une pénurie intérieur ou encore
aujourd'hui les infirmer un moment que
18 dans chacune des formations dotation
de la rs et d'un coup on se retrouve
avec une pluie de plusieurs centaines de
millions de marks annoncé près d'un
milliard réservé 70 millions en boutique
donc il ya quand même quelque chose que
c'est assez inquiétant là dedans et donc
la question est simple pour j'ai demandé
j'ai mis en demeure les grands groupes
de m le 20 août qui sont transparents
mais ils vont me donner simplement est
bon de commande
les bons de livraison non aller prier on
aura meeddat des avions ont l'état
dédouanement et on verra à ce moment-là
si l'on stocké à bord en chine ou en
france et comment ils ont ramené renaud
muselier
michel edouard leclerc vous a répondu ce
week-end pour lui il n'y a pas de stock
caché c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous a dit
égal
en tout cas ce qu'a dit aux sénateurs
edouard philippe cet après-midi et
s'exprime dans une vidéo sur son site
internet il parle même d'une polémique
débile écoutez temps des élus
probablement bien attentionnés mais
qu'ils disent
alors d'abord il y en a qu il trouve ça
scandaleux que ce soit des hypermarchés
qui vend des masques qu'ils regardent
qui fasse le tour du monde c'est des
débats il ya qu'en france pour sa part
tout que ce soit à singapour que ce soit
aux états unis à taiwan en allemagne ou
en grande bretagne
on trouve des masques à tous les étals
que ce soit chez les buralistes que ce
soit dans les pharmacies où que ce soit
dans les épiceries et les supermarchés
par contre je chante en plus des élus
comme monsieur muselier ou où le maire
de bordeaux qui eux ne comprennent pas
que aujourd'hui on est des masques alors
qu' il ya un mois il avait du mal à
doter leurs hôpitaux mais oui mais
c'était il ya un mois et depuis toute la
production chinoise s'est remis en
branle et même là la filière française
c'est maintenant qu'il commence à
produire ou qu'ils produisent en grande
quantité il faut pas faire procès de
michel edouard leclerc qui prend le
temps de vous répondre est ce que vous
êtes convaincu renaud muselier par cette
réponse convaincu dans ma question parce
que je m'inquiète beaucoup mais c'est
dur avocat michel edouard leclerc porte
des jugements sur les élus c'est bien je
ne porte pas de jugement en moi sur la
grande distribution et sur la voie en
compagnie monsieur leclerc dans le
sûrement au juste prix ce qu'il faut il
traiter normalement vraisemblablement
très bien son personnel c'est évident et
c'est tout à fait reconnu donc moi je
porte un jugement là dessus seule chose
qui est vraiment important que c'est
c'est pas de savoir si dans le monde
entier en vend des masques
heureusement quand on manque des matches
en entier sur que dans le moment clé il
ya aussi des masques pour les soignants
et nous ça fait deux mois qu'on n'a pas
de masque pour les soignants quand il
nous dit qu'il ya un mois la tension
était vous pouvez commander en chine
espère briller il ya un mois c'est
exactement l'inversé les américains qui
sont venus nous piquer nos masques en
chine
la tension était absolument énorme sera
chinois il n'y avait pas de places dans
les avions
comment il a fait pour les faire venir
et des sergents très fort ce magicien
écoutez je vais j'attends avec
impatience qu'on passe passe puis si
l'institution de lui c'est pas très
compliqué une grosse entreprise qui est
très connu qui côté je sais pas il nous
donne les bonnes comme horn et prouve
ainsi qu'il est tout à fait transparent
et il n'a pas fait une préparation d'une
france quand il aura l'autorisation
en attendant que les médecins et les
soignants à et la peur au ventre
travailler dans les hôpitaux à la
distribution mais ce que l'état
clairement n'a pas un rôle à jouer
n'avait pas un rôle à jouer de
régulateur dans cette affaire vous avez
vu que je fais partie de ceux qui depuis
des pas le zéro polémique avec les
tasser d'état ce matin en donne
pleinement raison à la grande
distribution et ceci contre les
soignants qui sont là depuis deux mois
c'est pas très bien si ces gens qu'elle
soit monsieur le caire mme la ministre
on vous tapez 1 20 heures dehors pour se
décider les soignants je suis pas sûr
qu'ils ont bien lu à télévision qu'il y
avait une guerre des masques dans le
monde et qui est donc un moyen d'y
accéder
si monsieur leclerc était si fort il
aurait peut-être pu nous tendre la main
pour essayer nous aider pour
dépatouiller dans les régions de france
où on a commandé 60 4 millions au mois
15 millions pour la région provence
alpes côte d'azur où j'ai donné
directement trois millions et demi nous
agressent et ceci gratuitement pendant
que messieurs le caire les ventes des
supermarchés et qui ne manquera encore
beaucoup pour la santé c'est pas le
problème
il en faut des masses pour tout le monde
de transport va revenir il faut du vent
je veux simplement savoir à quel moment
il comptait fabriquer commandé à savoir
si pendant que nous on souffre et en
première ligne mais elle n'y était
capable de la ce moment là avec toutes
les équipes de la grande distribution
le cerf des stocks en attendant pour les
vins ça s'apprend la question qui nous
fournissent quelques commandes et les
bons des maisons avec des transport
cargo
on y va arrêter alors votre début de
polémique
renaud muselier le prix 1 de ce masque
chirurgical qui est plafonné à 95
centimes d'euro l'ufc que choisir
par la voix de son président critique
ils achètent pour lui le budget est tout
simplement intenable pour certains
foyers
pour vous est-ce un bon prix moi je suis
pas conversion des masques selon
chercher en chiffres ça soit tout
simplement gratuit comme ça l'est
d'ailleurs dans certaines communes on
est de plus gratuitement
non chacun fait ce qu'il peut exclure
amont à une pénurie importante des mois
je pense aux soignants à tout ce qui est
par exemple un pharmacien qui a refusé
toute la journée par deux mois à des
gens malades des miles en mauvaise santé
qui pourraient pas dans ces masques ne
pouvait pas les donner bon eh bien c'est
comme ça ça fait hier est ce que je vais
dire qui mais tiers souci est de savoir
si au delà de la loi si elle était
respectée à part à mal les pages dévoilé
masque carrefour aujourd'hui heureux de
la un peu la morale quand même très bien
on peut avoir un peu de morale savoir si
ils ont mis dix sont organisés pour être
prêt dès qu'ils pouvaient le faire et ça
ça m'interpelle et ça me choque
profondément effectivement une dernière
question de nommer geôliers vous le
savez le sénat a rejeté ce soir dans ce
plan de déconfinement présenté par
edouard philippe une réaction peut-être
les sénateurs sont trop dures pour vous
la priorité aujourd'hui n'était pas de
des confiné où ils ont eu raison
finalement je pense qu'il faut des
confiné faut que chance qu'il faut se
battre pour trouver ces libertés qu'il
faut arrêter de poser des questions
supplémentaires derrière une autre
question supplémentaire pour des
questions complémentaires nous avec des
régions de france on ait pris une
position très constructive en disant
nous on pose une question la porte une
atteinte systématiquement ce qui permet
de traiter des problèmes des uns vers
les autres
on veut retrouver un produit de la tva
moi je ne suis pas fait pour être
enfermés et on est un grand nombre en
france comme ça aussi c'est dire
maintenant il faut sortir de cette
situation il faut reprendre en liberté
en gardant c'est le geste du sensation
se lavant les mains vous mettant des
sujets mais il faut s'en sortir et donc
aujourd'hui au sénat a eu lieu sur votre
politique
les gens de nous fallait les membres
grâce à des politiques et l'air se sont
abstenus donc c'est pas eu que
l'obstacle
bon moi je pense que dans une moments
difficiles et c'est très difficile pour
le premier ministre se retrouver dans
ces moments là c'est pas à peine de
compliquer encore plus la situation
il faut surtout que la carte numéro un
c'est à dire la transmission du virus en
france deviennent bien verte
ça sera en moins un gage de sécurité
pour un des confirmands rapide merci
renaud muselier d'avoir été avec mon
direct assure rt france merci à vous